so you have superhuman strength
and you can ship lasers from your hand
is there anything I'm missing
congratulations agent fury you have
finally asked a relevant question watch
this on March 8th
new captain arrives
how do I look fresh so those are the bad
guys they're shapeshifters noble warrior
hero what do they do not that's what I'm
here to find out don't answer that
war is coming
you can't do this alone
[Applause]
know your enemy
what are you telling me would you like
to know what you really are on Captain
Marvel with a pg-13 hey everybody its
charlie we got a whole bunch of new
Captain Marvel trailer footage to break
down and a concise origin story for her
powers that ties her to Iron Man Howard
Stark and explains why she's so powerful
like Kevin Feige and Marvel have been
hyping up how crazy Opie she is will her
backstory as it applies to Iron Man
Howard Stark Easter eggs would explain
why that's true there's a new brand of
the Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Captain Marvel moment on
the video first big thing couple new
shots you get more of her with Maria
Rambo in her house remembering her
backstory looking through her belongings
someone knocks on the door and they act
like it's a big threat it's probably
gonna turn out to be Nick Fury there's a
little more footage of Talos the scroll
leader entering the hangar here chasing
down Nick Fury and Captain Marvel as
they're probably trying to get away in
that shield drop ship there's more of
Coulson here in the background when they
first start coming together where she
sort of jokingly talking to him then
more per blasting these scrolls on their
ship in orbit you can even see some
pinball tables in the background like
there's a foosball table that they
destroyed there's a jukebox just
implying that they really like earth
culture but here's the thing this is why
Captain Marvel's new origin story is so
important in Wyatt mix are a little more
relevant and giving her ties to
pre-existing MCU canon in the other
characters it also explains the scrolls
Secret Invasion plot because there are
many more advanced planets in the
universe that the scrolls could try to
invade why is planet earth so important
well it all comes back around to Captain
Marvel's powers in her origin story so
think about it this way Captain Marvel
is from the 90s young Howard Stark in
the post-credits scene for the First
Avenger finds the tesseract
not long after Captain America goes into
the ice in the 40s so / his journals
Nick Fury's reports in the stuff that
Ironman learns about him when he's our
East uh deaiing all the stuff that his
father did during Ironman to Howard
Stark spends the better part of the next
few decades after this trying to find a
way to use the tesseract as the ultimate
clean energy source by the time we get
to older Howard Stark in the 80s Early
90s working with shield after its
creation he helps create project Pegasus
in the Dark Matter research facility in
the Mojave Desert the really
you see them blow up at the beginning of
the Avengers where they were studying
the tesseract so Howard Stark was
involved with that in the early 90s
before he was killed by the Winter
Soldier we learned about the iron man
connection to project Pegasus in this
history in that iron man to deleted
scene thanks to mark 6
front and center
so this implies a theoretical animal not
currently found on the periodic table I
think I will run a simulation to check
element viability yeah listen you have a
ball with that I know it's gonna work
miss take a shower
tap the Oracle grid and some stuff out
of storage come everything from projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath get ready for
a major remodel back in hardware mode
all those projects that he named were
things that his father was working on
before he was killed
the other big easter egg here is that
the element the Tony Stark finishes
creating here that powers all of his arc
reactors is based on Howard Starks
research he conducted using the
tesseract so not only is Iron Man's
energy source based on Infinity stone
technology Howard Starks tesseract
research is also the reason project
Pegasus exists here in the Mojave Desert
it's official operating mission just
reads that it was formed to investigate
phenomena beyond the range of
conventional scientific understanding in
a partnership between shield and NASA
just to experiment on all kinds of
alternative energy sources which is
where you get to tesseract research the
world's Security Council were the people
that okayed that and then you sort of
pay that off in the easter-egg during
the first Avengers film when Nick Fury
talks about enacting phase 2 and it
turns out that their phase 2 was using
that tesseract research to create
weapons so all their phase 2 research is
the results of earlier research that
they did during the 90s at this base
when it was created to study the
tesseract so while they're doing this
they're trying to use it to create clean
energy sources and obviously the
military wants to weaponize it and use
it for aircraft weaponry any crazy thing
that you could imagine which is where
you get to test pilot Carol Danvers who
just so happens to be part Kree it has
the biological potential for abilities
it is flying this crazy-looking
experimental ship it seems like the
tesseract experiments and all this
alternative energy unlocks her powers
when they blow up in her face during
this wreckage here with this other Kree
kind of looking ship it's hard to tell
if his courier scroll but she gets into
a dog bite they go down her energy
source that's powering her craft here
explodes and that's what activates her
hours so remember the new Scarlet Witch
cannon in the MCU since infinity Wars
come out Marvel has clarified that the
mine stone merely enhanced potential
that was already within Scarlet Witch it
didn't just grant her all of her
abilities or change her biology it just
sort of unlocked everything so now it
seems like both Scarlet Witch and
Captain Marvel have a shared style of
origin story although Captain Marvel's
powers would therefore flow from the
space stone instead of the mine stone
because the mine stone was still off
planet at this point in time
look at the blue energy rippling around
her when it explodes doesn't that look
just like the type of energy you get
when they destroyed the mine stone
during infinity war and then earlier
even during the first Avengers movie
when they're harnessing the tesseract to
open portals so it's just a really easy
way to tie Captain Marvel to the shared
history of the MCU and make her powers
relevant to pre-existing major concepts
the idea that Infinity stones unlock
humans powers so which is another big
payoff for fans that have been watching
the movies since phase one like oh wow
this is the same thing that happened to
Scarlet Witch that's how she got her
powers the other thing about tying her
to the tesseract energy is that that
would provide a reason for the scrolls
to want earth so bad because they find
out that Earth has the tesseract and
they want that energy source Ben
Mendelsohn explained that the Kree in
the movie have way more advanced
technology and weaponry so the scrolls
would want something to balance the odds
the tesseract would do that for them so
the phase forward of it all after
avengers endgame is that they need to
find a convenient way to introduce x-men
mutants and other biologically based
superheroes like Scarlet Witch and
Captain Marvel into the universe in a
really big way if they're gonna be
getting rid of Infinity stones and
messing with quantum energy there are a
couple of simple ways to explain how all
that happens like house and all these
biologically based power people pop up
all over the place
remember the Terrigen bomb from Marvel
Comics it transforms a giant chunk of
the population who were secretly
Inhumans activating their inhuman genes
so if the Avengers either destroy the
Infinity stones or unleash quantum
energy or misuse it in some way and easy
consequence would be that some of that
energy would leech out into the world
and slowly start activating people's
powers if they're not gonna do Inhumans
then there's a really easy way to
explain how Kamala Khan becomes Miss
Marvel because brie Larson and some of
the producers did say
that miss marvel is part of their plans
for future Captain Marvel sequels but
they haven't greenlit that yet but she
just said it at a press junket last week
so it does sound like they plan on
introducing Miss Marvel in one of the
sequels at some point Kevin Feige has
also revealed that they're talking about
doing an OVA movie during phase 4 that
would also spin out of Captain Marvel
quasar is another character that could
pop up in Captain Marvel sequels if
they're not gonna get their own spin-off
movie let me know in the comments though
where do you think that MCU captain
Marvel's powers come from and there will
be more Avengers endgame stuff happening
this week leave your video requests in
the comments below if you have any big
questions about the characters or the
movies that are coming up
congratulations to Cammy you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to learn why Netflix just
canceled the punisher in every single
Marvel Netflix show and click here for
my brand new Avengers endgame post
credit scene video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]